hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to evey hello a minute I'm
not seeing a nurse wait no I'm not
seeing a nurse you just thought that you
were oh no i'm markiplier no you lied to
me just go back a few lines how could I
lie to you it did wasn't a lie gods go
back a few I was not lie what Micah ding
ding ding ding okay alright okay alright
this started off I have never talked to
Evie before people have requested that I
talked to Evie for a long - a long time
and I thought it was stupid and I can
see what I could I thought this was
stupid and I could see that it was right
no I'm human being I know what I said
you're stupid I'm stupid
that's one I've never heard before
because no you're stupid stupid isn't a
word no you don't understand nothing
you don't understand proper grammar do
you understand yourself
oh I understand myself perfectly we're
all better than the robot like you don't
furrow your brow at me
I understand other humans better than
you do okay so am i what do you want me
to say then you do not understand I do
not want to talk about anything just go
home well goddamn it let me start this
over
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to talk to Evie
hello Mariah what a pretty name a pretty
common name because you were mean to me
to do anything to you you were mean
first you said you did something to burn
this is some [ __ ] here you take up
your attitude and you shove it back
inside your programmable ass it is not
silly I am bored it is 4:30 5:00 a.m.
know nothing funny at all hey don't
criticize my Let's Plays why is that
are you a big bad wolf not to cry
I say something's faulty with your
programming I do not have any
programming beatbeat you know see you're
a robot
beep boop bop I am an alien you are a
robot I must start typing cuz you are
super cool and hot ho ho mama funk your
cookies see now we're getting somewhere
what is your name whatever you want it
to be baby wink oh you know me love some
baby winks but let's save that for later
let's see um do you want just do the sex
I've gone the huniepop method on this
woman oh great mom
whoa that worked I think she knows about
huniepop apparently but she looks bored
and looking off into the distance my
your smile is beautiful now it would
seem cheap if I said the same to you but
he ordered see we were off to a bad
start but now me and Evie we're really
bigger than that your eyes are like
sunshine and rainbows on a rainy day
they're like pools of water [ __ ] what a
beautiful compliment will you marry me
we're moving a bit fast here yes I will
marry you you make me the happiest
person alive wait what
but are you really alive no I'm dreaming
as far as I can tell it's because it's a
dream to be married to me oh when can we
get married when do you want to get
married I've always thought a summer
wedding would be the best Twitter on you
all right who the hell is Willa
then who Lu I'm markiplier I'm Qi is
that German
I'm markiplier no it's not
I thought we had something special I
thought we had something special
you're a girl not a guy tree tree of
what now whenever depending on your
perception I didn't say when will it be
lauryn jumper this is baloney I don't
like this this is getting weird
let's back up a bit hang on is there
anything you would like to say to the
audience I would like to say hello to
make fun okay hi Meg Han Evie says hello
Andy we might want to marry you in a
couple of sentences how many days would
it take to walk from Pittsburgh to New
York City Wow
no it is the amount of months in one
year multiply that by 15 174 I was just
curious
you were just creepy creepy in bed whoa
oh my god no don't look at me like that
don't see he's God no no no creepy in
what way in the past away
so you like to get freaky goddammit stop
stopping do you want me to leave right
after we got to the spaghetti lovin if
you want it laughs laughs is good for
the health the past man okay oh my god
this is so weird
this is so bizarre oh she she's either
very very dumb or just messing with me
and I don't like it either way so that's
me talking to Evie it's been demanded
four years practically so I finally did
it so there you go everybody let me know
what you think of this horrible tragedy
of a conversation was let me know if you
want to see more and remember I'm
seananners so whatever is that he
doesn't even do an outro does he thank
you to the 50 Niners away